when JFK was assassinated in November
1963 the entire world was taken by
surprise yet one aspect of the
assassination of often discussed is how
the USSR the United States rival in the
Cold War felt about it so how did they
how did the USSR react to JFK's
assassination
well news of events reached the USSR
mere minutes after they occurred in the
USA in the wider Soviet population was
in a state of shock in the halls of
power this shock was also present and
one of the first things that the general
secretary of the USSR Nikita Khrushchev
did was to make a statement denouncing
the assassination and given his
condolences to the USA the new president
lyndon b johnson and JFK's Widow Jackie
Kennedy publicly the image was one of
calm solidarity with the United States
behind the scenes it was one of blind
panic
the KGB immediately launched an
investigation into whether art it or any
of its agents or contacts had anything
to do with the events and the answer was
no and the upper echelon of the Soviet
government would have been comforted
when an American Lee Harvey Oswald was
arrested what's that he's a Marxist who
used to live in the USSR oh boy the KGB
investigated again and discovered that
they never at any point tried to recruit
him whilst he lived there since he was
seen as unreliable the USSR opted to
share all of its files on Oswald was
quick to offer their assistance publicly
because they really didn't want to be
blamed and Khrushchev wasn't too keen on
the idea of nuclear war for the Soviet
Union and its leadership the days after
the assassination was some of the most
dangerous it had ever lived through
barring the obvious the KGB believed
that JFK had been assassinated by the
far-right who would then blame the USSR
invade Cuba and then start a nuclear war
some higher-up didn't believed this
version of events but was still
concerned that a leaderless USA could
see a rogue general fire a nuclear
weapon at Moscow in vengeance as such
the USSR took the position of a friendly
and open assistant with anything the
Americans wanted and as a result of this
uncertainty the entire Soviet military
was placed on high alert and
preparations for war were made
throughout the entire Eastern Bloc
Soviet leadership also had reservations
concerning JFK successor LBJ since they
had no idea what his personal opinions
were was he going to have strict
policies concerning the USSR or was he
going to be open to cooperation at the
time they didn't know when not knowing
made them very uncomfortable it wasn't
long until they got their answer when
LBJ blamed the Communist conspiracy
rooted in Cuba for the assassination and
promptly
escalated the Cold War for a brief
moment the Cold War had ground to a halt
with Eastern West United in grief for a
u.s. president however international
politics waits for no man and it wasn't
long until the Cold War was back on
track again I hope you enjoyed this
episode and a special thanks to my
patreon supporters James Bissonnette
John lucid Danni Maloney a man of
culture
Marvin Castle John bisko's moe Rob
Waterhouse James Castaneda Aaron the
white Jordan Longley Gustav Swann Marcus
oz nur Rashid Ali filled oink-oink easy
spinning three plates David Silverman
Maggie packs Kowski Spencer Lightfoot
Winston K word Robert Wetzel Anthony
Beckett
Lexi Schwinn sky Chappell and Kelly
moneymaker Castro was also sad